113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
number 15
why do so many animals love playing in
the snow
recently over on twitter i shared a
video that's been
you've probably seen it by now this
this panda bear is sledding in the snow
this was like the first big snow day at
the zoo there
and he is having a blast now he's
probably
i mean people are arguing maybe he's not
so much playing as he is scratching his
back
he just really likes to do this but
i used to volunteer at the portland zoo
and it never hardly ever snows in
portland
and what would we do every once in a
while is we'd go down to the ice skating
rink and we would get
trucks full of ice shavings which is
basically like snow
and we'd bring it to the animals and we
put it in their enclosures
we just we just switched between
different animals we'd you know one day
we'd be doing it for the
you know for the bears one day we'd be
doing it for the beavers and
the otters and so on and i was amazed
at how almost every single animal when
you put snow
in its enclosure some of them right away
they're really excited to go play in it
some of them are scared at first and
they come very cautiously and they test
it out but then something clicks in
their head and they start playing and
they just start having like the most fun
that you could ever imagine an otter or
even even birds will do it i've never
i don't think we ever gave birds snow at
the zoo but there's videos online you
can you can see of crows that are
playing the first snow
there's there's one of a crow that is
learning how to sled
on a rooftop if you if you type in
youtube like sledding crow
you'll find it it's hilarious like
animals love
playing in the snow and like
why is this what is it possible that
this
is an adaptation that has evolved this
desire to play in the snow or is this
just like a random fluke that
animals just like to play in the snow
well if
we think about what the purpose of
playing is from an evolutionary
perspective
the whole point of playing you watch
dogs play fetch
what they're doing is they're practicing
their skills at moving their body
they're practicing and in the case of
playing fetch their the dogs are
actually they're pretending to hunt they
really like the ball if it squeaks when
they bite it because it makes it sound
like a real animal like they're killing
an animal
they'll bite onto things and just rip
them apart
vicious the whole point of play is to
figure out how your body works
in various different situations this is
obviously
play is most common in children and it's
because children
are trying to learn how it is that
they're supposed to move their body
around and
play is a really good way to do that in
a safe environment
there's play fighting there's we play
with words even in
like things like poetry and so on and
we're
really what we're doing is we're
sharpening our skills it's hard to tell
if snow specifically if there's like an
instinct that animals have to
get really excited and play in snow
specifically or if it's just that
there's something crazy and new in my
environment i'm gonna go
explore it and have fun and play around
in it because it's safe right now
and i want to be able to know how to
deal with this later
when things might not be safe right i
mean animals don't know that's why
they're playing when they're playing
humans don't know that's why they're
playing when they're playing but if you
stop
and look at it from an evolutionary
perspective that's what we're doing
we're practicing so that when things get
rough
we know how to deal with the snow we
know how long we can stay in it
until we're too cold we know how it
packs when you press it down we know
what it's like to try and run in it
and all this we learn through play and
the animals are doing the same thing
they get
very very excited i wish that i had
footage
of the black bear at the zoo because we
had the coolest
it would it it really was amazing seeing
this happen
we had an orphan black bear and the
story of that is actually
kind of interesting how it came to us
actually well i'll go ahead and tell you
that story too
so this bear there were these people in
oregon that lived kind of out in the
woods
that if they had farmland that was next
to some forests
and they went out their dog they had a
big
like a golden lab or something like that
they had a big dog house for their dog
outside he was an outside dog
and one day they're calling their dog
and their dog's not coming to them
and so they go out to the doghouse to
check on him and the dog is
cuddled up with a baby black bear so it
must have been an orphan
and it attached to their dog as its
mother
and you know obviously that's super cute
when the bear is a cub
and uh for whatever reason they decided
we should probably
tell fish and wildlife about this um you
know maybe it's illegal to have a just a
black bear on your property
just hanging out with your dog keeping
it as a pet probably it is
i'm pretty sure it is um but so whatever
it was they contacted the officials
and the officials contacted the zoo like
do you guys wanna this cub
it's not really gonna be releasable
because it's been living with this dog
and these people for
several days now and i can't remember
the details of
like how long the family ended up
keeping the bear i think they kept it
for
at least several days maybe maybe even
several weeks before we were able to get
out there
but uh yeah we we had this baby cub
and when she came to us she was
extremely
depressed i don't remember he or she but
the cub was super sad because it had
attached
to this dog and uh the dog was no longer
there
and so we wanted to you know wanted to
find ways to
to make the bear happy and someone
suggested let's bring the bare snow
and i'm thinking that there's no way
that's gonna work this bear is
it's never seen snow it's it's a it's a
it's not even a year old
so i don't think that's gonna work but
all right so we went down to the ice
skating rink we got a bunch of snow
and we put it out and you know
this is the bear is still in quarantine
which is really cool because you can get
right up next to him
we couldn't be in the enclosure with the
bear but you know that the bear would
just
it'd be chain link between us and the
bear and it was just so fun being that
close to one of these amazing animals
but
the we had to put the bear in a little
pin
while we were setting up the snow and
the bear couldn't see us or the snow
while while it was in the pen and it was
crying it was just crying crying crying
for its mom crying for attention
and we
we finally get the snow all set up we
spread it out a little bit so it's got
like a little snow yard to play in
and the bear comes out and it stops
crying it's looking at us
it's it's looking it's just like looking
right at us it's like
you know are you guys going to play with
me or something and it turns around and
it sees the snow
and immediately it gets excited it just
starts
running towards the snow it dives in it
as if it knew
what snow was somehow and it starts
throwing it up in the air
and we made the mistake of not
anticipating how excited this bear would
be because we actually put it next to
a cement wall and as he's running back
and forth
he's looking at us like for approval or
something
and then he runs back to the snow and
throws it up in the air and
one of these times he he ran towards the
snow looking at us
and he slid through it and he slammed
his face into the cement wall
and he was just bleeding out of his face
and he had this look
like like he'd just gotten in trouble
you know just
like what what the heck heck's going on
and he's touching his face and he's
he's looking at his paw he's licking the
blood off of his paw
then he sees the snow again and he just
freaks out again
and just starts playing in it and he's
flicking blood all through it
it was pretty funny i think someone had
filmed it
but i think the like the zoo staff
didn't let us post it online because
uh you know people are like oh he's
bleeding so
it's like animal abuse but i mean
animals get hurt playing all the time
right
kids get hurt playing all the time the
bear was fine but
it was it was really interesting just
seeing that
uh level of intensity of play that this
bear had a desire to do
and i think that it it's definitely
possible that bears
that live in the snow in areas that have
snow
seasonally it's definitely possible that
they do have some sort of an instinctual
desire to play in the snow when they
first see it because
because playing in snow is so important
for them to learn how to maneuver in the
snow
when it really does snow and they have
to hunt in the snow they have to
travel in the snow they have you know
they have to deal with the coldness
of the snow so it would make sense that
they've evolved
an instinctual love for snow
and maybe that explains even humans love
for snow
you know i mean the first snow day
i live i live in montreal we get pretty
sick of it after a while
but the um the first snow day really is
like
exciting and you'll see you know dogs
get excited and
people get excited and bears get excited
uh so yeah i
what i can tell you is that play has
evolved
to help us learn how to deal with
certain with our bodies in different
environments
that's that's pretty well established
what's not really well established is if
there's actually
a special drive to play in snow or if
it's just
oh look there's a big weird new thing in
my environment i better go play in it
and have fun and learn a bunch of stuff
about it so that i can deal with this
later if it
you know if it remains here so that that
is still a little bit
mysterious to me but the way that this
black bear immediately ran towards the
snow
i'm gonna say uh it's definitely
possible
that there is an instinctual attraction
for black bears
and snow so i'm gonna just leave you
here
um showing you this bear again
this this panda bear this is pretty good
just loving that snow
i mean i think probably these
playful behaviors are exaggerated in
zoos as well because animals get so
bored
and at zoos and and they feel safe i
mean
you play when you're in a safe
environment but yeah
why do animals love to play in the snow
well play is an adaptation
to help animals learn how to use their
bodies
next question